what you're looking at here
is referred to as the unfinished
northern pyramid of zayet el aryan or
the pyramid of baca
and when i tell you what the egyptian
authorities have done to this site
you're going to be really really upset
so first of all
look at these incredible photos of
something that you've never even seen or
heard of before at least not likely to
have
because this has been off limits to
tourists and any type of excavation
since it was placed around a military or
within a military compound
back in the 1960s now as you look at
this giant corridor which is more than
75 feet deep
this is carved out of not dirt not
sandstone but
solid limestone bedrock which raises all
kinds of questions on how
the dynastic egyptians could have done
this because although yes the
egyptians did have bronze chisels which
can cut through
limestone it's unbelievably difficult
and it's not a practical use whatsoever
because you're going to wear down that
bronze chisel
or pickaxe so unbelievably quick which
raises the question on why are we not
finding
hundreds if not thousands of discarded
worn out bronze chisels and pickaxes
throughout ancient egypt or this site
particularly
now first of all let's just debunk the
fact that it's being referred to as an
unfinished pyramid
many in the mainstream claim that it was
although others have said no it's very
likely that it wasn't a pyramid
case in point well it's in the shape of
a parallelogram
find me one other pyramid anywhere in
the world that is in the shape of a
parallelogram
not to mention although other pyramids
have the subterranean shafts
they're incredibly small and you can't
even stand up within them and this is
clearly something completely different
but what makes this even more incredible
is the size of the granite stones
that were placed on the floor of this uh
temple or corridor i mean look they
refer to this as a tomb as that this was
a sarcophagus as you see this
oval type well bathtub or sarcophagus i
mean that's what they're referring to it
as
i don't think that's what it was and and
many others have suggested that it was
something else maybe something
ceremonial
maybe some sort of site used to look at
the cosmos and you know who knows what
tons of speculation nobody knows because
there's no other site like it
there's no other sarcophagus in egypt
that is in the oval shape of this
and one of the things that makes this
site so interesting besides the fact
that it's dug 75 feet deep into solid
limestone bedrock
is that when you see these shaded
flooring granite uh
blocks on the flooring here that's rose
granite
so part of the site is regular granite
but those shaded parts are rose granite
which the closest site in egypt where
these could have come from
is from elephantine island more than 500
miles away
from the pyramids of giza which by the
way i almost forgot to mention
this site is located approximately five
miles southwest of the pyramids of giza
and when you consider just how massive
these blocks are i mean we're talking 15
feet long eight feet high five feet wide
and then compare that to the 100 ton
stone boxes found at the serpion
outside of cairo egypt and we're talking
30 tons for the solid stone lid
and 70 tons for the boxes i mean does
anyone watching this have an estimate on
how much something like that would weigh
i mean that could easily be 100 tons
apiece but why would they go to such an
incredible length
to carry these massive stone blocks down
this uh
causeway which by the way one of the
stone blocks is a complete mystery
because it's so large that they know it
could not have made the corner
once it got into this t-shaped uh area
so how did they bring it down there i
mean obviously they must have lifted it
down while it's being constructed i mean
it's one of the mysteries of this site
now the site was first excavated by an
italian
archaeologist in 1905 and as you see
these photographs they were taken in
1905 and some of them were taken in 1921
and the only other pictures of this site
since then
is from 1954 when hollywood paid a visit
to this site to shoot it for a movie
called the land of the pharaohs
and you can see it here it's been
digitally remastered into color and
these are all the photos that exist of
the site
not since 1964 has anyone been allowed
to visit it
because it's now within a military
compound tourism is prohibited
archaeologists excavations are
completely prohibited
and here's the part that's going to make
you really upset so the egyptian
authorities
have been utilizing this site as a local
dump no joke inside this military
compound they are throwing trash into it
they are allowing the wind to carry the
sands into it so they don't have to
utilize any type of heavy machinery to
cover up the trash
and it's since been filled up and here
you can see an aerial photo of what it
looks like today
completely unrecognizable and to quote
some german archaeologists
the status of the burial shaft is now
uncertain and most likely
disastrous guys i'm not so sure this was
a burial
chamber of any kind i mean i can't say
it's not i'm not going to tell you it
wasn't i mean how do i know
but there's something really odd about
this it almost looks like some sort of
industrial
grade something i mean why it's one
thing to line the floor with granite
blocks
i mean why would they choose blocks that
are so unbelievably massive
again 15 feet which is four and a half
meters by eight feet which is two point
what five meters and by five feet in
height or deep i should say
and not to mention this when you look at
this uh oval sarcophagus or bathtub
whatever
you want to call it again i think it was
something else what exactly
i have no idea it's just that when i
look at this site and you got to keep in
mind as you see this stone block here
that was
laid down horizontally as they found it
they feel like it was part of something
else they have no idea if there was a
roof to this structure
but there has been much debate within
mainstream itself saying that well we
just don't know what this
was and there's a lot of reason to
suggest that maybe it wasn't a chamber
or a burial chamber whatsoever
i mean after all when they found this
site the cover was sealed shut and when
they opened it there was no body in it
so i mean come on like why is it that
they haven't found a single
tomb within any pyramid or this site yet
there's something called the valley of
the kings
which is just loaded with incredible
artifacts and how many i mean how many
kings have you found in there
dozens and dozens and they keep finding
new ones so i don't know there's just a
big hole missing this story
clearly and keep in mind they have found
almost nothing in this site whatsoever
as you see here these are just some
inscriptions that they found on some
tablets in there
and that's it so besides the fact that
the egyptian authorities are clearly
i mean you could call this a cover-up i
mean even literally not just
figuratively i mean they're
burying the site with trash what is that
about and this is something that's so
incredible
i mean again when you look at these
walls here it is unbelievably deep it's
just awe inspiring on how did they do
this why did they do this
now i would never even heard of this if
it wasn't for this awesome youtube
channel run by a guy named chuck and his
youtube channel is called cfap cfap7865
i'll include a link here in the
description you need to go to this guy's
channel
and subscribe because he is literally
digging through books and looking
through information that nobody else is
talking about
or people don't even realize exists
absolutely check out this guy's channel
he has so many different videos on so
many different topics within ancient
egypt
and i've just been incredibly inspired
by this guy so definitely check out
chuck's channel he gets my highest level
of recommendation he's a wealth of
knowledge
and you are guaranteed to learn things
that you never would have known
otherwise
so check him out anyways guys look at
these photos let me know what you think
i mean honestly i think we're looking at
something just
incredible we have to really utilize our
imaginations to think about what this
may have been
so many thousands of years ago and we
also have to open and entertain the
possibility
that this dates pre-cataclysm i mean
there is evidence here that the dynastic
egyptians have visited the site and
utilized it for something
but again how do they cut and carve
through solid limestone bedrock this
deep into this
precision why did they go to such
incredible length to cut and carve
and move granite stone blocks from as
far away as 500 miles
just to line the flooring with this i
mean and again a oval sarcophagus or
bathtub whatever you want to call it
i don't know guys i think we're looking
at something absolutely incredible that
goes far beyond well
what the mainstream archaeologists and
egyptologists have been stating
and again why on earth would they
prevent tourism
why would they prevent excavations why
would they bury the site
with trash think about that anyways guys
i'll leave it at that i'm jimmy this is
bright inside like and subscribe and i
have many other videos to come and a
whole wide variety of topics
take care everybody